こんにちははじめ出張です皆さんが票を知ってますねあの僕て骨格嫌いなんですよね見
た目が通ったようないっとなんかほろりと5秒左側の4年で前田が敏感になっちゃうが
ビルダーが病って何かと言いますとね大澪香ネカフェ時半とかに貼ったりポスターとか
ほっパンで貼る時に4つ角に果て留めておくと落ちなくなる針がついているさ吸う奴な
んですけどもうヤバ
んですよもうが分鋭さがもう普通に危険物ですね全然私小学校の時にやっぱりが病衣
過ごしたに贈って遊びが流行ってめちゃくちゃ痛い応援したことがあります最悪ですと
いうが妙なんですけどもこれ皆さんも分かる通り足元とかに置いてあるとめっちゃ怖い
院長二部とか普通についてるじゃなくシャーシにそんな恐ろしいが妙なんですけれども
このがビューですねかんっ
単に梁の部分でさっとれいいですよで撮るとこんな感じになりますはいもう綺麗には
泣いてプレゼン前組んでも言いたくないんですよ
ですがこのが秒パッっと見て下さいパッドからちょっとぼやけで4コアこの状態だと針
が付いてるか付いてないかわかりません
港近くで見たら様へグァハリがないとわかるんですけど上からご覧ください相当家にし
ないとが
用の針がついてが付いてなきゃとわかりにくいと思うんですよなぜかと言いますとが病
って別に針がすごいわかりませんじゃなくてほどの金色の丸いこの感じこれ=が病って
認識が人のどんなにあるんで張り出しの壁合わせに降り立ったとしてもパッと見ると
普通に貼り付け眺めると勘違いってすごいなんか踏むのが強くなっちゃうんですよ
今日はすぐを使って行きたいと思いますここに画鋲戦後準備しました今から個の
画びょう戦後の針を全部脱ぎます
あっ今から戦後抜いてと針がついてね画鋲を床にきれいに並べてそこに誰かを盗んで
突き落としたりこれは出るとぞーなんとかやってみたいと思います最低
グっていこういいと思うよ針が1個付いてないとしても金色の
この裏があるだけで人は公園でそれが線カルト
どんな評するのかなぁでは寝ていこう
ちなみに貼り抜け止めっつあんふぁんたんなんですよね10時に1個くらいで普通に
できます張り持つ武器んだとを持つ
でっ
オラってやると剥けるんですよこれでもう完全にさせてもいいたくない奴完成ですこれ
を1000回やりまーー
コレなにがでるなぁマジで農場にできるんかこれちょっとそんなレベルで不安になって
くるぐらいの仕事量ですね
なんかちょっと太めの毛を抜くみたいで楽しいですね
[音楽]
はい
多分一人で300本がやったんですけども2時間くらいかかりました
このペースでいくと多分
すみます立ち上げして最後まで作っていこうと思いますでは
[音楽]
1000個が秒あたり抜き割増してうー
ええええええ
[音楽]
いただければ物やの4時間かけて二針専門の木はありました
花瑠子の作業したの準備初なのではないでしょうか意味が分かりませんもうマジ意味
わかんないんですけどこうする時間外
絶対にもポイントがビューと思うする人って張りなんと細って見えないっすも給与下
早速が描線金払えばいいねえ人にいろんな人底に突き落としてみたいと
思いますでは以下を回収じゃないけど
改修完了ですうわぁ凄いてみましょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
ん
めっちゃ塗ってレベルだ
持った
[音楽]
今回の誰かの声がこの床です吉倉早速並べていきましょう
は怖いね道路これ見えてきて声もや靴にが夫婦はこれどう見てもキャラももれ見れて
あげます
よねー
面族させん今夜はロックだけど相当やばいぞこれ
me
さあ配置が完了しましてもさあご覧くださいこれ全部が病なんですはい上から見ると
本当にねメッツ機能に光ってるから結構怖いですよね普通に
月でが病だと思いますこれパッと見にヤバイさあこれからどうするかと言いますと言っ
てないよねふんでも俺そこへずらしまあいいんですよ
まったく題された以前にまだ1オーナーが適当に選んで本の上に乗せます目隠しして
この上に乗ってもらってこれが[ __ ]でもさだけはい的な人間の心理を生かした
素晴らしい動画だと思います針を抜いてもが病だと思い込むこと間違いなし+愚民の
地獄の底に
た時を通してみましょう
[音楽]
よく来たな2楽章しろやもう怖いー
今すごい
付け根の時という救える終え交通議会でみー回転右さいって見えないから
そう入れ
で鉄オタって皆さまでここに立ったちますはい終わりました
よくでしょ怖いだちょっと支えてもらえば本県に入った
ダメな目隠しでを外してくださいいたしますよはい今入った
に sh ちゃん何を映したみたい
5やばいやばいやばい待って番してませんガチでヤバイ
マンしてやばいは誰
えっちゃんがちゃんとばしゃべるからはい悪くてもいい
皆さんいたくらいだからなぁ向かって同じく不安大会第二大隊
まーやー早い
ブロッカーだったんだろう4
何本当に行きたかったんや本当にもう絶対住んで落ちたねーか
ゆいってダウン電球られたよ創造ですねこれマジで引っかかるってかもうそれにしか
見えなくなるんですよね次行きましょう
[音楽]
まず思う待って気もするね
でちょっと左に再度すっ
海外
ここです立ってください
ません
女学者としてください
[音楽]
な配布
うわぁ
笑われてい
薬用ですん
ran わー
ああああああ
[笑い]
うわぁ
いやいいん
ねえヤバイってうわぁじゃーっ
お風呂るはぁああっもう
声楽視聴あざしてくださいはい
[音楽]
ブーブー
ぐっぴょん
j air いやーよえっ